what's going on guys national master james canton
iii here with chess.com and today we have game of
the day with the white pieces we have stock fish
and with the black pieces leela chess zero let's
get right into it guys it's a very exciting game
we have e4 e5 knight f3 and knight to c6 and then
who doesn't love a roy lopez guy especially
to b5 classical games you get classical stuff
or sometimes even better when you watch these
engines play knight of six in berlin fashion
and we have d3 here to defend the pawn one of the
most solid ways to play not only does it lock the
bishop outside the pawn chain temporarily maybe
we might back it up sometimes in the classical
roy lopez's and stay on this long diagonal to be
able to play d4 after we play c3 and at the same
time it also uh develops our bishop or gives us
a scope for the bishop that we would love to use
so after d3 bishop to c5 from black just saying
hey if you're not going to play c3 if you're not
going to take over the d4 square i'm going to
take over the d4 square also put my bishop on a
very nice square here and also put some pressure
on the f2 square just a soft point for for white
so after bishop to c5 we have bishop takes c6
and then we have d take c6 now a lot of times
guys you should take take towards the center is
the rule actually you want to capture towards the
center but in this case actually this pawn could
be hanging on e5 now let me ask you this guys if d
takes c6 like what happened in the game would you
take the pawn on e5 is that a yes or no from you
would you take the pawn on e5 this right here
knight takes c5 would you make this move for y
the answer here is actually whatever you want it
to be if you're going to say yes okay you can take
the pawn but is it the right answer actually is
the question here knight takes c5 this is not the
right move guys we briefly looking at it knight
takes c5 just because there's a pawn that you can
capture does not mean you should actually always
take it you need to look for checks and captures
what would they actually do if you take this pawn
here and if knight takes c5 there's queen to d4
and this is already over guys this is already
over queen queen d4 is attacking checkmate on
f2 and also a double attack with the knight here
so no matter where you go if you go knight to g4
i'm just going to take uh remove the defender with
maybe bishop takes or knight takes g4 followed by
crashing down on f2 with checkmate so no problem
there guys you can't take on and on e5 so actually
the engine of course didn't take on e5 and played
castle getting out of the way now this pawn is
actually hanging and we actually defend it with
queen e7 from lila chess then we have knight b to
d2 here guys we have to develop looking at this
position you also had moves like bishop to g5
which is more a human-like move knight c3 as well
but i do like knight b to d2 a lot because these
knights are very nice um and they they just cover
each other just in case of course when the bishop
comes to g4 which is slightly annoying that's
exactly what happened to as well it's bishop to g4
so you have some a friend here that can help you
unless you move it the next move right here right
to c4 attacking the pawn on e5 actually and also
in some cases playing stuff like bishop to e3 and
after bishop takes you can actually take back with
the knight to be able to attack this bishop just a
little bit more because a lot of times if this
pin happens guys you can't untangle sometimes
and you find yourself as a human playing stuff
like h3 and g4 when you have to open up the king
side that's not always recommended sometimes
they even sacrifice and you find yourself
in a very bad position but the knight was covering
here but stockfish has other ideas knight to c4
and then after knight to d7 defending the pawn
we have h3 indeed trying to kick the bishop away
ax the bishop what are you going to do of course
we're going to back up and keep the pressure here
bishop h5 and then we have interesting move here
guys what would you actually play here with the
white pieces take a moment and look around the
board pause the video if you need to what would
you play here is why the answer actually uh from
stockfish is bishop to d2 guys now i think bishop
e3 could have been played as well and uh maybe
even stuff like maybe c3 rookie one but these
are kind of slower moves i really like bishop d2
or bishop e3 just because you have to develop guys
you got to get the pieces off the back ring and
bishop d2 actually has a dual purpose move with it
not only does it develop but it also maybe
has some attacking chances on this side
or helping us push pawns on this side of the board
let's keep watching the video and after f6 a4 so
here's a4 we're stopping b5 not only stopping b5
but maybe a5 a6 so if he tries to castle queen
side which seems absolutely ridiculous maybe he'll
be in trouble and we'll already be ready right a4
and then knight to f8 interesting move wants to
put the knight on just a better square here if
you go back and look at where the knight was the
knight had no good squares this is a gross knight
i mean it literally has nowhere to move except the
b6 square which really doesn't do anything at this
point so knight f8 very very nice strategical move
here actually knight of fate and then b4 guys whoa
wild move from stockfish here just plays b4 would
you expect it and a lot of times you want to make
these kind of moves um with your opponent to
make the unexpected kind of moves and see if
they actually work here now if bishop takes b4
were to happen guys what would you actually play
this is not the game move but what would you play
in bishop takes b4 what is the intention of this
b4 giving up this move here now i will tell you
the human version of it or most people would do
bishop takes queen takes followed by rook to b1
and then taking on b7 that's what probably would
happen but actually and that's what i looked at
too i was like just take and play rook b1 maybe
but actually the best move was queen to b1 in
this position and after queen b1 it actually
attacks the b7 pawn and if bishop takes him we do
queen takes b7 hitting the rook and the c6 pawn at
the same time and the bishop is hanging all at
the same moment guys we would have moved there
queen b1 was super cool but in the game actually
leela chess was like i'm not gonna do that
and play bishop d6 and just backed up now of
course at this point this bishop is now what we
call a big pawn because it can't do anything it's
not doing anything it looks just like one of the
pawns so after bishop to d6 we just put a little
bit of pressure on the file while also defending
the b-pawn rook to b1 and knight to e6 from leela
chess as we're just going to get that piece into
game into the game we move to f8 we don't want
to keep it there same thing if you keep a knight
on the rim you want to get him back into the
center as quickly as possible we moved it to e6
and then we have knight to a5 here attacking the
b7 pawn interesting right how do you defend it
how do you defend it maybe like rick b8 right
rook b8 seems sensible seems like a move to
make but here's what leela chest did guys here's
what leela chest zero did castle queenside wow why
would you castle to this side of war now i always
tell my students things like this all the time
you always need to question the engine always just
question it sometimes they may seem like they're
wrong of course the engine knows all but at this
in this kind of case guys who would castle to this
side of the board because of everything going on
it seems like you're so much safer to castle to
this side of the board right but actually lelich
has zero said i don't care i'm leela chad zero and
castle queen side here and let's see what happens
next guys this is very good this is gonna be very
fun so if i'm playing white here what would you
actually play castle queenside it's your move they
just castled you have a rook on a b file a knight
on a5 ready to go what are you going to do here
white to move here it is b5 b5 open it up open it
up and it was like huh we're not opening anything
look at this bishop guys worst piece on the
board right looks really bad here and here
we go stockfish makes a nasty move here knight
to c6 okay we're forking the queen and the rook
at the same time and then b takes c6 and then
b takes c6 and now we have to do something so
black's like well let's figure out what we do i
mean we need to get away somehow you know let's
see what happens and here it is after bishop
to g6 guys after bishop to g6 white to move i
hope you had your tactics today i hope you had
your tactics for breakfast i hope you do your
tactics every day it's right to move you finish
it off what do you do here white to move guys
stock fish played here it is rook v8 check wow
wow look for checks and captures guys look for
checks and captures first the moves that you
don't consider are sometimes the moves that win
the game on the spot rick b a check king takes
queen b1 check and no matter what you do check
mate next move king a8 and queen b7 check mate
beautiful way to mate and it happened literally
seconds after castle's queen side guys this
is why you should never castle into the
attack where are the pieces aiming at probably
don't want to castle to that side now of course
these are engines playing but it was just nice
to see guys b5 c5 knight c6 beautiful way to
finish this off and if you move the rook then i'm
going to take the queen you take the you move the
queen i take the rook very simple so after takes
um takes takes bishop g6 i mean there's really no
way to get out of it actually here either
but uh bishop g6 rick b8 takes and check
and checkmate guys wild game i hope you
enjoyed it guys this was game of the day
i'm national master james canty iii with
chess.com and i'll see you guys on the next video